[Musica]
pregi siamo natalizi quindi cioè ci usi
una volta l'anno puoi anche farlo sforzo
poi siamo antiscivolo Dai su Andiamo al
dunque Che fine ci farai fare eh ci
farai fare Prandelli dal tuo Jack Russel
ci venderai a 50 centesimi su vinte ci
lascerai e farla muffa in quel cassetto
come mai
ma regalaci a tuo nonno sai quanto
apprezzerebbe e certo lui ai piedi un
po' callosi e non proprio giovani io
preferivo te però so adeguarmi Eh certo
Eh pensaci
E allora non dire che non ti piaccio
perché ti faccio venire l'orticaria
prima di proverai per far contento tua
madre no no non iniziare questa storia
che pigiami non ti servono che ti fanno
schifo Innanzitutto fanno schifo dice
tua sorella poi sono morbidissimo è solo
colorato sono bello Bello avvolgente e
meglio di così potrei andare eh e
signorina lo so che preferivi uno
smartphone nuovo o il buono da 500 euro
da spendere il tuo negozio preferito Ma
sei andata così e ti è andata bene
perché tu un giorno mi amerai E comunque
ti ci ha donato non si guarda in bocca
non era così Ma va bene uguale
Jingle Bell Rock
Sì sì sono proprio io di Natale che ti
mancava quello col cazzo gira che
ascolti da quando sei nato esatto no
scusa In che senso non si ascolta più cd
ma io sono il regalo più apprezzato
dell'anno Che anno siamo che non siamo
nel 1998 mi stai dicendo che sono
vecchio non ti permettere eh ragazzina
Io al massimo sono vintage mi sono un
attimo incupito mi viene da cantare una
canzone malinconica tipo
[Musica]
Cosa si usa adesso bonifay mai sentita
questa cosa sarà una moda passeggera Io
sono stato sulla cresta dell'onda per
decenni vogliono vedere quanto dura
questo qua
Sì sì sono
l'agendina un po' anonima potrei
starella anche Sai sono un po'
autocritica Vabbè non mi userei mai non
mi offendo No tanto e intrinseco proprio
nella nostra stirpe nel nostro DNA siamo
abituati a stare lì impolverate
sull'ultimo scaffale però ecco se magari
un giorno decidessi di iniziare a essere
un pochino più organizzata io potrei
aiutarti
potrei essere la tua di anonima
preferita se non vorrai fare lo stesso
davvero non ti preoccupare di ferirmi
Ciao sono un libro motivazionale No
tranquilla la tua vita è perfetta non
c'è niente che non va
Sì lo so che in questo momento stai
pensando che la persona che ti ha
regalato me sia una brutta persona Però
mettiti le sue mani
tra un tua mente Albert down e l'altro
ha semplicemente pensato che un libro
che si intitola 10 modi per raggiungere
la felicità se ancora in tempo per
cambiare la tua vita di merda potesse
essere il regalo perfetto poteva
regalarti un'altra cosa sì forse sì ma
non l'ha fatto tu la chiami coincidenza
io destino non importa se ci metterai 1
2 3 mesi tu mi aprirai e inizierai di
nuovo a sorridere respira rilassati
sorridi La vita è bella
[Musica]